i'm doing all right man about yourself
doing excellent i know why you're in
berlin and i couldn't be more [ __ ]
excited
there we go you know i wouldn't i
wouldn't expect any different of you man
yeah i know you i know you stay on top
of it super excited uh i want to start
with listen first of all great work
in chicago 7 movie is fantastic um
i just want to start with the other
thing is congrats on being part of the
best series of 2019
also known as watchmen thank you very
much i appreciate you
that means everything yeah the
unbelievable series um
jumping into why i get to talk to you
today yeah you've obviously done
you've worked on a lot of different
things but did you as an actor
did you put even more pressure on
yourself for chicago seven because
it was aaron sorkin it was bobby and it
was
this story this was probably
there was no pressure everything about
this was a privilege was a privilege
this was probably the most
this was one one of the
i want to use the right word the easiest
jobs to get up and go to and to prepare
for
you know since i've since i've graduated
just because
it it every every this with this job as
an actor it rewards you
immediately almost like the
gratification that you get from theater
because i got that i got to have to turn
those pages to get into the script i
have to listen to the dialect
return back and i'm learning about
history so i'm being rewarded
at every turn and then i go and i sit
down and even on the days when i'm not
talking
i'm rewarded because i'm in the presence
of uh of
of of great really really great actors
so this was rewarding from
from you know from top to bottom and
there was very little uh
that was you know a present there was a
pressure situation in fact that it's the
opposite
it was one of those iron sharp and
sharpness irons type of situations on
this project for sure
i would imagine filming those court
scenes with all those people
um had to have been just an amazing
experience and even if maybe you're not
on camera
you're like effort i'm not staying in my
trailer i'm on set no yeah yeah i'm
gonna go watch aaron work mark rylance
work i mean i think
just about all of my scenes with the
exception of one were opposite mark
riley so i had a very good
working relationship with him uh uh
even uh kelvin you know kelvin harris uh
you know was
sitting right behind me and you know we
got to you know develop a really good
relationship it was a master's class
every single day um and aaron really
really really teeted up you know with
those words in the script and
even everything down to the set
decoration and costume left very little
to the imagination or left very little
uh
uh necessary you know uh for the actors
we had everything that we needed
the film takes place in 1968 um as you
watch it
you can't help but be angry at the way
bobby was treated by that judge
it is outrageous that that was able to
happen
um the way he was treated uh can you
sort of talk about
the way he was treated in this like by
this judge and maybe what are the things
you were surprised to learn
when researching yeah well you know you
look at the way that he was treated
being
being bound and gagged in in a courtroom
that sounds like something out of it
that
only belongs in a movie or or some
somewhere in the novel but to know that
that happened
uh as late as uh 1969 i believe
uh that that's that's that's infuriating
you know
you know just just as you said but it
also shows
the lack of uh regard for uh
for black lives you know uh during that
time you know i think
um in a lot of ways we have not moved
past the possibility of moments like
that
um and and so you know i also
carry carry with myself a lot of
responsibility to accurately tell those
stories and to tell that story with a
lot of dignity as well
this was a lesson in terms of what i
learned this movie was a lesson in
dignity
lesson in uh humanity and lesson lesson
and carrying on
uh or leading the charge for your
for your cause with dignity and uh and
with absolute courage
because it was it was tested that you
know tested at every turn
the thing is that when you were making
this i don't think that
you guys could have any idea of the
timeliness
of this film especially with what's
going on now
and what's been going on i mean for many
many years
can you sort of talk about the
timeliness of this film
yeah sure you know we did make this the
knowing that it would be an election
year knowing that
the move will come out sometime around
the election and that was really the
attitude
that we was making this you know with is
saying hey it's important to make your
voices heard to get out and vote
uh you know to make your voices heard
through being coming involved in the
political process
but this movie has taken on an identity
uh
or of its own or i think that it will
based on where we find ourselves in the
world you know this is a this is
the you know the the refrain that that
repeats itself in the trailer
the whole world is watching is now it is
an absolute truth you know there's
really all eyes on on the on us and in
the us
young people in the us people from every
for all generations
and uh everyone is wondering how how are
we going to respond
to our to uh you know to
the current uh oppressive uh pressures
that are being placed upon us
what are we gonna do and so this movie
hopefully is a call to action to let
others uh to lead others to stand up to
get
uh to get uncomfortable to create on to
create a positive discomfort
and to really demand uh demand action
and uh change
i i hope so um before i run out of time
with you i definitely have to ask you
about
uh matrix because i'm a huge fan uh i've
heard through the grapevine that the
script is
fantastic uh i want to know what your
reaction was reading it for the first
time and meeting with lana for the first
time
sure my reaction to the script wow
people are really going to like this
you know i said you know wow you know i
like this people are really going to
like this
it's it's different and it's the same
you know at the same time so it's a
really really
very intelligent blend of what we want
and
what we don't know what we may have what
we may not
know that we want um my my first meeting
with lana uh was
um wasn't even really an audition it was
it was just that it was a meeting it was
a you know
really about getting to know me and
getting to know
her and uh our our histories and how i
am as an actor you know lana is um
lana was was interested in creating a
family you know before she was
interested in creating a cast and so i
was very fortunate enough to
to be welcome welcome in into that
family you know uh
and to be over here in berlin with that
team making something really special is
this is a it's definitely uh something
that i'm proud to
you know probably say i'm a part of
cannot effing wait
yeah yeah yeah yeah man congrats on
everything um have a great
shoot uh stay safe all right appreciate
you take care